Sammy is 12 years old and says he loves
us this is Sammy are you a boy or girl
Sammy I'm a boy and you're 12 yeah I
wanted to say I'm a huge fan of yours
and I used to watch you a lot on ADC and
the first time I listened to your radio
station you guys had hypnotized al and
he was screaming about losing his penis
that was a very important show by the
way Sammy Sammy I'm curious if you don't
mind I'm I would like to develop more of
a twelve-year-old audience um which of
my let's call them staffers characters
on the show who do you like I like he's
like really funny
Ireland is it because is it because Sal
is like a 12 year old to you would you
Sammy would you like to speak to your
hero Sal prevalent well Sal your biggest
fan is on the phone now it's al you
didn't put this kid up to this did you
no I I got um I got cheered up listening
to are you so sweet I mean you know all
these years you get beat up and then
somebody says they like you Sammy talk
to well stay out of it you talk to Sammy
who idolizes you go ahead Sammy I think
you're an awesome child and you're gonna
make your parents are very very proud
and a lot of children should be like you
you know you could jump in yeah I think
crying ham salad nice job to cry this
hard it's just it's just really it's
really nice it's just so just sweet you
know what all the Bulls excuse me we're
all their bull crap going on I want to
be I want to be respectful to Sammy it's
just it's just nice to hear that it's
nice to hear that you're having a
positive impact on somebody you know
Sammy but I do want to warn you Sal is
very damaged is there anything you'd
like to say back to your hero that now
that you got in getting to speak to him
go ahead um thank you I mean just thank
you you don't worry what I think back on
all the things you must love about Sal
all please here we go
I'm a turtle what is Sal done that you
heard she was hypnotized he when he was
hypnotized Robin I got about 50 spins I
can tell you right now but I ain't gonna
do it with Sammy on the phone please
don't do you like when Sal is running
around naked with Richard that was good
yeah listen Sammy I'm gonna advise you
something you got it at some point grow
up and start laughing at Sal rather than
idolizing him that's all I'm gonna tell
you you know oh you don't
Sammy I was an honor to speak with you
and thank you that was great have all
the things in my life by 12 year old
male the [ __ ] I've been through in
my life
you